welcome back everyone
to our next episode of dc thursday
i'm pete soderling i am your guide
through the wild west
of the data ecosystem and we're happy
that you joined us for another episode
today we're going to be talking about a
really interesting
advanced topic in machine learning um
actually two topics one is adversarial
machine learning
which we'll learn about more briefly and
the other is federated learning
which is a interesting technique recent
that helps us separate the models
from the data and satisfy some privacy
requirements
so fortunately we have a great expert in
the field
uh to join us and to illuminate these
topics for us
natalie barcaldo um natalie
works at ibm and natalie we're
really excited to have you today thanks
for joining us
thank you i'm very excited to be here
with you today
that's great so just to make sure that i
get your
title right um natalie you're the
manager of ai security and privacy
solutions
and you're a research staff member at
ibm is that right
that's right yeah double hats two cards
right two hats
two hats well i wanna start with some of
your education and the earlier part of
your career which is
um something we typically do here to
better understand the context
um with which you your interest in data
come
you know comes from um so talk to us a
little bit about
your phd your thesis was on insider
attack detection
can you can you tell us more about that
and what that means
yeah so i think it's a really exciting
topic because organizations usually
spend a lot of money uh creating ip
intellectual
uh property and a lot of three different
assets and the problem with insider is
that
basically the employees that you're
trusting all of the saturn good rush
and i start uh trying to get or steal
some info
information extract some information or
sell some of your intellectual property
under the the hood
sometimes they are also interested in
just sabotaging
a company and so forth so it's a very
big problem
actually there's a lot of big profile
cases i i'm sure you
know which ones i'm talking about and
it's it's very difficult to actually
detect before
these uh incidents occur what's going to
happen
so my thesis was all about detecting
before they occur who who in a company
seems to be likely to commit one such
insider crime and um
the idea was basically try to combine
the risk assessment of
profiling different employees depending
on the accesses
depending on how they behave uh what
types of
emails they are exchanging a whole
plethora of information
and put it into a machine learning model
combine it with risk and trust
and based on the behavior and basically
decide when we should be monitoring some
very closely
um so so that was uh the overall idea
of of of the thesis that's really
exciting topic
to work on so so it's basically a
a sort of um age-old security
concern which is insider threats but
then you
applied a machine learning or a data
lens
over the top of it in order to to try to
gain better insights or make more
efficient decisions
exactly and then uh one other piece that
was really important
was incorporate that into the access
control system
because what happens is that if you
don't have that connected to the access
control system then
if it's somebody manually verifying and
removing uh
the different accesses without knowing
what's going on
it will take forever and uh frankly
uh it's not going to be very efficient
so the next piece that we incorp that i
was incorporated
was adding it to the access control
system
and uh sometimes you don't really need
to
remove accesses to everything but rather
have the assets in the company and
information in the company
right rank by like very relevant so
that's highly risk and less relevant
so we would remove access to the things
that are
very relevant and very important and you
really need to protect these assets or
our intellectual property so
we stopped that with the access control
the idea being that we are
really perceptive of what it's going on
and
preventing those those data exfiltration
problems
okay that's interesting so so did this
system work its way into industry
anywhere
i don't think so i don't think so there
are
a bunch of different issues uh some of
the
aspects that were for instance we were
proposing monitoring certain actions uh
in social networks and so forth
which actually are privacy sensitive
and um also collecting all that
information
uh it's it's uh kind of difficult in
some cases it may be
good for military settings for instance
uh because their people
are do not have any expectation of
privacy necessarily
uh but uh for certain companies
especially in europe uh
there's a lot of legislation there are
some
some approaches that exist out there and
ibm has some
uh but i don't think it's as uh as kind
of a big as the thesis which was really
an exercise of uh
understanding different uh different
factors
and defining him yeah okay understood
so then how did you end up going from
your studies and your phd
um to ibm like what what's the story of
that journey
yeah that's uh actually i first
they offered to happy as an intern
i went for internships first
and uh i kind of liked it there because
people are very very knowledgeable and
teams are super exciting
and when i graduated um they offer
a research staff member position so i
guess they also like me
and i came back as a research staff
member
and i started just working in projects
that were very different to what i
did uh during my internships and
yeah so it's one of those things that
ibm research is so
big and varied that there are a lot of
different problems you can work on
okay got it um well let's let's talk a
little bit about
um adversarial ml because
um was adversarial ml related to your
thesis or or not
that's a really interesting question so
you heard me talk about
we have a bunch of data and then we want
to create machine learning models
one of the issues that we have in inside
our tread problem
is that the data that we're collecting
is actually coming from employees
and we are trying to detect suspicions
of malicious
employees but guess who's providing the
data
the employees right so there's there was
a lot of potential to
actually for them to poison the model
and start uh creating kind of backdoors
or uh reductions in performance of that
machine learning model so that at the
end of the day
you get a very bad system and
it doesn't matter how much you invest on
it right
so i try to add a chapter on that in my
thesis and my advisor said it was not a
good idea
but this kind of kept in the back of my
mind
and after that when i started working in
ibn
with iot devices and trying to create
machine learning models on top of those
devices
okay so there again you have
and i guess uh my mind always wonders
that way
and it's it's really a threat that you
have all these devices
and you're making important decisions
and
do you actually have a way to monitor
that somebody is not manipulating those
devices
and providing you data that it's not
know
what it should so there
i i started expanding more and really
starting to create solutions to
solve this type of problem and i
realized i didn't mention what a
poisoning attack
is or yeah but here basically what i
mean is uh
the machine learning model it's uh like
a black box that you usually train
with a lot of training data that's kind
of one of those things that you need
to get a lot of data especially if it's
a neural network or something like that
and then this data is assumed to be uh
usually uh when when you're trying
talking about like standard machine
learning
you're just usually talking about data
that it's uh
clean that it ideally kind of covers the
distribution of the entire population so
if we are talking about insider attacks
that you brought up before
then we would be assuming that the data
covers
very well the things that people are
necessarily doing and things that
they didn't and a poisoning attack
basically is
when somebody manipulates the data so
that the decisions that the machine
learning model
uh provides are really either
bad so that the system performance is
it's
downgraded in which case at the end of
the day nobody's going to use
the model and people are just going to
be like oh this is always giving me the
like worst predictions possible
or there are other types of attacks uh
where
for instance an adversary is really
interested
in misclassifying a sample and
they add certain triggers as part of the
sample
so just a super super intuitive
and i think a scary case would be
you are driving in an autonomous vehicle
and there's a stop sign you are
kind of relying on your vehicle to be
able to detect that stop sign if it's a
fully autonomous vehicle uh but you
don't want to crash into another car
you don't want to get a pedestrian or a
pet or
any other kind of bad situation and
uh what has been shown is that if the
adversary has access
to some of the training data that um
that stop sign is going to be
misclassified
and if your car doesn't identify that
there's
this stop sign and it thinks it's a deal
there's a
but a bad bad situation and that's just
one of those examples
of uh how things can go south and
you can extend it to different critical
applications like uh
airports or uh anything where you really
need to
alive that decision uh that that that's
actually very dangerous so got it so you
became
very interested in these abuse cases of
of training data where attackers could
potentially poison the training data
and cause the system to classify
something incorrectly
that's right yes and i think i
became there are other types of
adversarial machine learning attacks
but i really think this one is in
particular important
to solve because if from the beginning
you cannot have a model that you trust
then uh it doesn't matter any of the
other attacks
so the other attacks that happen at a
prediction time and they don't
manipulate the training data
but if uh from the beginning you're
broken
well i guess in my in my opinion was
like
we first need to solve the issue that we
gotta train the model
and that's why i'm very excited about uh
providing solutions to solve that
problem that poisoning problem
got it and and so what what are some of
those solutions i'm i'm curious to
understand
how you protect a model from something
like this
that's a great question uh one of the
there are different scenarios
uh one of the works i have and the first
one
actually that i i did in this area was
related
to considering the contextual
information
of where the data is coming from to
identify
whether for instance a potential source
is it's uh
providing wrong data so rem
imagine an iot scenario where you have a
lot of devices
iot devices deployed to an edge
and one of the use cases is for instance
if you have
a city uh in a country that it's very
polluted and the mayor of that city is
trying to create
a machine learning system that allows
them to detect
when certain factories in that city need
to be shut down so that the air quality
for everybody it's good
so i think uh if i live in that city i
am
all for it i i like them but at the same
time there are profits
so there's an incentive to manipulate
that data
and the devices that are uh distributed
to basically monitor the air quality can
be manipulated easily
say to uh very close to to a factory
so that the system would not detect when
that factory is causing
and a bad output and
the idea there is that you basically as
an adversary they don't have really
access most of the time in
an iot system to manipulate all the
different
factories or all the different sensors
across the city that's probably not
realistic
but they have uh access to certain of
those
and they can manipulate the data that's
uh it's uh collected there
so the idea is basically to understand
how
that contextual information uh can be
incorporated
uh as part of the training process
to drop data that it's uh really
reducing
the performance of the model and you
there were before i started working on
these there were other approaches
but because they did not use this
contextual information they were
slow to train and you also want
something fast
and what's an example of contextual data
um
the firmware of the device of the iot
device would be for instance
one of those contextual data if you know
for instance that there's a
bug or a exploit in a device
and you know all this information about
the devices you
can probably verify certain
versions of all the iot devices as
contextual information
that's one example i know ego location
so uh different geo locations around
the city would would you can filter and
organize your data
that way and start verifying how the
data
so the idea here is that you would
reject data that came from an unknown
device identifier or if a device had
been moved
from the geo that you expected you would
you would reject the data that that
device was sending is that the general
idea
uh not exactly so what we would do
is basically take all the training data
but
let me just explain first how it usually
happens so you collect all the data
and you train a single machine learning
model that's the
vanilla case unprotected uh but here we
have this protected data
this uh data that came from different
sources
and also next to it we know where it
came we know all this contextual
information we know the firmware
and so forth so we basically take the
training data
and sort it based on a particular
feature of that provenance information
uh that that contextual information and
start
training uh models and verifying
for a group of devices for instance that
had that
that type of uh firmware how they are
affecting your final model
in some cases if they are really
dropping or reducing the the
accuracy of your model you don't want
that data um
because then you know that it may be uh
coming from an infected
actually device it i see so
so it kind of gives you a way to take
all the data
contextualize it and see how that group
of data
as opposed to a single example affects
the entire model mm-hmm
got it okay interesting um and
and so then um some of this this work
manifested itself
in an open source project ibm is my
understanding
tell us about that yeah so this is a
very
very big library it's called the
adversarial robustness
toolkit toolbox uh art for short
and uh these it's uh it's huge uh in
that
it uh basically tackles different types
of
machine learning threats across the
pipeline
so today we have been talking because i
work a lot in poisoning about the first
stage which is poisoning data but then
there are other threats related also to
evasion
so you already have a model deployed and
people try to manipulate that
the the train the data that comes for
prediction
uh to get get it misclassified we have
also attacks and defenses for those we
are also
uh have things related to uh
data exfiltration from models so
imagine that uh pete you are part of a
training data set
and somebody really wants to know if uh
the model that they are seeing has your
data
so they would start trying to uh
if if that's the case so we have attacks
defenses
we have metrics because uh what i like
to say
it's uh what you can't measure you can
control so we also have
metrics uh in there for all these types
of uh
attacks and defenses i see
and so it sounds like a quite a large
project how many people
across ibm worked on this project and in
other companies were other companies
involved as well
um so originally it was uh an ibm
project so i i started there from the
beginning
and it grew right now i think uh we are
at least
15 people working on on that one way or
another
but it it's actually open source now
and it's open to the entire community
people are participating it's uh
i actually don't remember the number of
stars that we have but it's a huge huge
effort
um people are contributing to it and
this is a very active field so
there's a lot of uh energy going on in
there i i definitely
uh invite you all to to check it out
great yeah i'll uh i i hope our users
check out the adversarial robustness
toolkit it sounds um interesting and
like it solves some sophisticated
problems
yeah yeah it's still a lot of it's not
an easy
problem so i think it's it's great that
we have that
uh one place where the community can uh
add their attacks because their attacks
change
a lot and also their defenses and
this is kind of uh one of those exciting
fields where
i don't think things are fully solved
if you have an idea and you're curious
about it i think
it's a good research topic so
so then i guess that that makes a little
more sense to me
as to how you got into federated
learning because
um ultimately in your career
up until this point you were um dealing
with data from multiple sources
sometimes being aggregated into
probably a single model what are the
parallels between what you were working
on
at this time in the adversarial ml and
then sort of how you got
interested in federated learning um you
know walk us through how that transition
happened
that's a a good question so sometimes uh
one issue that we have and this had
happened since my thesis actually
is that getting quality training data
it's not easy
uh people have private data
that they don't want to share
enterprises are
are subject to legislation so they
sometimes cannot move data from one
place to the other
and move it to a centralized single
place
uh there's like gdpr um
the hippa here in the us really
you cannot transmit all the data to a
single place and
at the same time i personally feel very
strong about
privacy and the fact that uh
we are building these models and
i think uh ideally we should not be
collecting
that much that many data points about
everything that we do
so from that perspective um
it's it's actually a good segue to go to
federated learning where you can tap to
a lot of data
that you didn't have access before so if
i
if i want your data you don't have to
give it to me or we don't have to
transmit it to a central server
but we can both collaborately uh
find a single model for for both of us
and you don't need to see my data either
so from that perspective
i i think um it's one of those
breakthroughs
that can help the society and the
companies and
everybody uh to to get better morals
yeah of course um i i guess
the the classic example of federated
learning
um is the the autocomplete that we see
in many mobile
keyboards now right is that um do you
want to walk us through that and how
that's an example
of federated learning then we'll talk a
little bit more technically about how
federated learning works
awesome yeah so i i think everybody in
the audience actually has a
mobile device i would think uh now
when you're typing you probably uh are
doing like this
and you notice that you get this
prediction for the next one
now uh have you ever start wondering how
they are predicting what's the next word
that's that's uh when the machine
learning model comes
in so there's a machine learning model
that helps them predict based on what
you have typed so far
what's going to be the next word now to
train
the machine learning model you basically
would need all the data from everybody
what people are typing which clearly
apple
or google they don't want to get that
data that's a lot of
private data there's a lot of liability
like no no that's there's no way
so federated learning comes into play in
that each of the
phones that you have that people have
in their in their homes are with them
they
basically contribute to the training of
a single
model that helps everybody predict
what it's the next best word
uh without getting any of the training
data which in this case is the text
messages that you're writing so those
stayed in your device those are yours
and
they they are kept in your device uh no
transmitting
but still we get like this really good
predicting model
uh that benefits everybody
got it so everybody has come across
federated learning
um at some point um literally through
their mobile keyboard
and and the autocomplete and the the
predictive text
yeah so you're already using federated
learning even if you don't know
right right well i i also know that some
of the history of federated learning
um was was literally sort of about
mobile devices right because that's such
a great example of
devices or sensors on the edge
if you will and um so it seems like
um some of the earliest federated
learning interest
was based on these mobile type use cases
is that fair and can you take us through
a brief history of the origin of
federated learning
definitely so the first paper that used
the term federated learning
came into 2016
and it was by google and they were
describing this use case
about people they trying to create one
single machine learning model
for the smart device we
were just describing
so i guess the the first set of works
were really either from google or
apple trying to do these to protect the
privacy of their
smartphone users um
yeah so that's the inception uh here
important is that there are some
assumptions that are made that simplify
the
the problem for instance we all have the
same device
or the same uh software so
probably things are already annotated we
don't need to
go into a lot of pre-processing uh
that's different for each device
so from that perspective uh that step it
was assumed initially to be kind of done
and simple
but as we started seeing this and trying
to apply it to
the enterprise setting we realized that
there are a lot of different
aspects that need to also be considered
so uh enterprise settings for instance
we have um what's on health uh trying to
use uh federated learning
to predict uh based on images uh
like x-rays and so forth there each
hospital may have
or each side may have a slightly
different data and it may
be annotated differently we need to uh
do a lot of pre-processing and so forth
so that's one of the of the differences
of what we are seeing
and what i'm working on is really try to
take the federated learning and make it
available
for the enterprise setting another like
a
super huge uh difference in what we are
seeing in the trend is
that think about smartphones again how
many of people do we have
lots of people brilliant lots of devices
so training there the algorithms
you don't really need to worry about
including everybody necessarily
and it's a simpler in the sense that you
have so many
people contributing uh but in an
enterprise setting imagine like five
banks
you cannot do some samples you really
need to make sure that you're
um kind of at considering how the banks
are doing
make sure that you have your model
affected
the right way by each of the banks and
so forth so the scale it's uh also
dramatically different
the data is different uh there's no
pre-processing so these types of
problems i think uh
are are slightly different from what
the original uh learning was designed
for
i see so this is the the modern era of
trying to take federated learning into
the enterprise
well that that makes a lot of sense um
well why don't we talk a little bit
about how federated learning works
um at a little bit deeper technical
level sure
do you want to walk us through that yeah
i can show a slide if that's oh that
would be great
let's do that all right let me see um
so yeah so i i wanted to show this slide
because
it kind of uh really demonstrate
demonstrates uh what we are
doing and the different entities on the
system so
okay here we go so
this is how this works uh the magic
happens here so imagine these
parties and just because we have been
talking about smartphones
each of these parties is actually a
smartphone you can think about it
and each of them has their own training
data that's why i put this little thing
in each of them um the this training
data can have something like x
y so this is the sample for instance an
image or your text message
and the label if we are doing something
like a classifier
um and so the aggregator here
this one it's going to orchestrate and
orchestrate the entire
training process the aggregator
basically first sent
a query to each of the participants this
query uh you can understand it at
something like uh
give me the gradients for this neural
network
after you have trained so each of the
parties uh
in that case will take that query will
use their data
to train or to answer that query
and then send back the reply
to the aggregator
with that the aggregator takes all those
replies which again
they don't contain any private data they
only contain
the information about either weights of
gradients
uh if we are trying to train something
based on
uh neural networks or sbn something like
that
or if you can also even uh train
decision trees
in which case this reply it's just the
counts so it's not
really the training date itself the
aggregator takes all of those
and creates a single model so that's uh
basically
the entire magic about what happens
underneath
the hood the important thing here is
that um
we never move the data so your text
messages are yours
if that's what we were using for
training
and and what and what um algorithm does
the model use to aggregate
and create the the combined model
there's a plethora of algorithms a lot
of different algorithms
uh depends also in several things the
type of machine learning model that
you're training
so uh sometimes you are training a
neural network it's
very easy to aggregate by just having a
simple average
there's a very popular algorithm that
weights the replies based on the number
of data points that each of the
parties has that's another but there's
a whole set and maybe i can just show
you
just to give you a sense of how big it
is
uh here
so this is actually
something that's uh
this whole set of algorithms here that
these are the basic ones
but there's also a bunch of them that
are advanced algorithms that try for
instance to exploit the
structure of the neural network uh
some of them as you can see here are for
xgboost
which is another algorithm that you can
train we have things
special for differential privacy and to
protect privacy and so forth so there's
robustness algorithms all sorts of
things
i see so there's many options for the
way that this
um this combined model is is created
indeed yes yes uh that's one of the
interesting uh things about federated
learning and
it's kind of a very productive research
area in that there are a lot of issues
uh each of the parties uh
or banks or smartphones may have data
that
it's not necessarily uh distributed
according to the same distribution so
these algorithms tend to
to work to overcome those barriers got
it
and i wanted to ask you specifically
about the federated averaging
algorithm is that one of the original
algorithms used
um for this type of work uh yes
fed up was one of the main ones uh
because it basically it's very simple so
you take
the replies and weigh them by the number
of samples so
if the two of us are training a machine
learning model and i have 100
points my replies and you only have five
my replies will have a higher
weight because i'm contributing more to
the system
yeah yeah
um well that's that's fascinating um
natalie thanks for explaining
how that works and it sounds like
as you mentioned federated learning can
be applied to
um more traditional machine learning
models to neural networks
to the it's being used it's a it's sort
of a
mathematical solution that's being used
um across the field it sounds like is
that right
yes yes and the algorithm that you run
uh it's really dependent on what machine
learning model you're running
you're trying to get at the end of the
day
got it um cool well let's let's talk a
little bit
um you know let's move from that into
the combination
essentially of the two topics which is
um
federated learning plus new attacks
because um your career has been about
sort of blending
this the security of something with um
data
about something and so it seems like um
there's a clear path now for you to to
start to research
not just federated learning but also
some of the attack surface on federated
learning is that fair
no it's exactly what i'm doing right now
and
what my research is currently about is
really trying to get federated learning
see
what can go wrong and then trying to to
solve it
uh i can again share like some slides i
think
okay that'll be great easier to kind of
explain
but basically there are kind of um
oh i just uh
let me just look for it but basically
there are kind of different thread
models
uh for federated learning and
um the one of the
key things uh if anyone in the audience
sits in the security field the first
very thing that you do is try to see
what can go wrong
and see what's the risk and so
one of the risks that we have it's
actually
related to inference attacks so
remember here over here
i will re animate this one uh
we didn't exchange this data
but uh usually if you don't exchange
does it mean that you're really private
and does it mean that that's enough
and if you're a security person you will
tell me
depends i cannot answer that question
just yet
give me the context so it turns out if
the company is the same
that it has all these parties and they
just have the data in different clouds
that's enough that's most probably
enough just not to
to transmit the data maybe just enough
but if you are in a more untrusted
environment there are two things that
may go wrong
the first one is in french threats so
and here it's what i mean one of the
issues that we have
in the machine learning world is that
once you publish a model
then an adversary may try to exp to know
whether a training point was part of
that model
so this is the training data and
the adversary basically is trying to
query whether bob
was part of the training data
and you may think to yourself why would
the adversary want to do that
now imagine that you know that this
training set was
a for people that had aids
then all of the saturn you already know
that bob happens to have aids which is a
prior
privacy violation
in a more enterprise setting uh it may
be
that the adversary is trying to see
whether somebody is going to acquire
a startup and that may be part of the co
of the uh the training data that was
used
all the documents and so forth then
that's problematic again
so that's one of the threats uh this is
not specific to
federated learning it's but it's uh
really
all across every time you have a single
model that you have trained and you put
in the wild and people can query
then we have this problem uh
this other thread is really specific to
the much
to the federated learning in that here
we are talking about these replies that
are sent throughout the training process
and in this case uh there are a bunch of
different attacks that people
have proposed in the literature to know
what data was used so even though you're
not really
uh transmitting the data it is possible
to know for instance you transmit it as
serious this example
uh if you're training um model for
text classification and you happen to
use a bag of words
then it is easy to see that at a
position
of non-zero means that somebody actually
got
got award again in the example of i'm
trying to
buy a company that's that's uh really
uh worrisome and more recently
people have also tried to uh
achieve the exfiltration of data for
instance uh
was somebody in the picture wearing
glasses
uh like some property that it's part of
the
of the sample even if it's a kind of uh
something that was not even
part of the original training decision
that we're doing so
so these are kind of the inference
threats that and may occur
and with legislations like gdpr
and hipaa like people are are getting
worried about this
because so so both of these threats are
used to
expose um specific
facets or aspects of the training data
or even
um down to individual level information
that may have existed
in the training data that was used to
originally train the model
exactly exactly so
so we need to protect against this and i
could take you
briefly through some of the solutions
that we have
if that's interesting yeah that would be
great um i'm i'm curious
like have you seen um like clear
examples of this
in the wild are there sort of known
cases where
um models were were attacked this way
um for this one uh
i think this one is a little bit more in
the wild as you say
um uh i am
not aware i i know there's this data set
that where they keep all these uh
different types of um incidents that
have a curve with machine learning
models i haven't checked if this there's
one for this particular use case
uh this one i don't think there's
there's uh
somebody has actually said hey this is
in the wild it's uh probably
very researchy right now got it
partly because it's it's um sort of
combined with the federated learning
model which um probably isn't
in widespread use yet even though um its
adoption is increasing
exactly exactly
okay great um yeah well why don't you
take us through some of the solutions
that that'd be fascinating to better
understand how to protect models against
these kinds of attacks
yeah so some of the solutions uh the
ones
uh that that are out there for instance
is having
some data noise added to each of the
queries at the end
before replying to the aggregator and in
that sense uh you can think about it
like a possible deniability
sort of thing because you're adding this
noise so at the end of the day
what the aggregator gets and the reply
that you're sending kind of has
that issue the problem this is known as
local differential privacy and each of
the parties has
because each of the parties has their
own noise the problem
with this is that this basically means
that we have end time noise that's a lot
of noise
and when you have a lot of noise what
happens
your motor performance just drops and
it's just plummets
so that's an issue and we try to combine
different techniques from the security
field to
reduce the amount of noise that we have
so solutions that use multiple
computation techniques
for instance are important uh
very briefly multiply computation
techniques what
that means is that if pete sends me
some cipher text and that's encrypted to
the aggregator
and i also send the aggregator my
ciphertext
encrypted the aggregator can take all
both those cipher text
and combine them and find the model
update without
ever decrypting the information
so if you combine that with a
differential privacy you can actually
kind of reduce the the noise
substantially
and um that's that's kind of one of the
things
um so i have this one that it's just
like to match me in heaven
and just to see like uh you get like
really
good uh results and i know i'm getting
too technical so i'm going to stop there
just to say
that part of the work that i do a lot is
to try to reduce the training time
and explore different crypto systems uh
to see
how we can target uh a bunch of
different
techniques yeah so yep got it
um and so so a lot of your work sort of
terminates in
um another open source project from ibm
is that is that right the federated
learning library does that include
um techniques for for both using
federated learning and also protected
federated learning
talk to us a little bit about what that
toolkit is
okay so ibm federated learning uh we
have a community edition and a product
uh the idea there is that we have
compiled a set
of um of different algorithms
and uh one thing that we notice is that
if you try to do
federated learning in reality
you do need like very strong plumbing uh
because
these parties are in one cloud when some
parties are in one cloud some parties
are in other
data centers and maybe behind fireworks
so remember this is
this is like completely different system
so uh we created something that allows
us to easily
deploy the code to each of the parties
and all each of the entities and then
communicate with an aggregator
that can be either at the cloud so as a
service
or it can be uh in the
um in a private cloud if in for instance
cloud pack for data
so that it's kind of available in its uh
the framework ibm fl kind of has that
on top of that we designed it so that
when we come up with a new fusion
algorithm
or privacy mechanism we can easily put
it there
and just basically start the entire
federated learning process
and the other interesting thing is that
if you are a data scientist and i kind
of consider myself a little bit of a
data scientist
i already know how to grind my machine
learning models in kira's
so i was really really pushing for
this requirement and i i want to use my
kira's model
and i want to specify it uh the way i
usually do
i want this to be magic for me so
you basically bring your model in kira's
or in python
or in sk learn and at the end of the day
there's magic
and uh just through a jam of files you
get your final
favorite machine learning model
got it um very interesting well we
we had an interesting comment here um
daniel is mentioning
that model manipulation is actually
confirmed
in some music streaming scenarios
music music recommendations and top 10
lists apparently
um and it sounds like perhaps there was
a
data scientist or someone at spotify who
um commented on this so thanks thanks
daniel for
mentioning that we'll make sure to check
that out as an example of
some of these attacks occurring in the
wild um but that makes that makes sense
that it would occur in something like
spotify where they're
you know trying to rank music perhaps by
by popularity um uh publicly
you can see how somebody may want to do
that
yeah right yeah exactly um
well the the ibm fed red learning
library sounds
interesting natalie are there
are there a lot of people contributing
to this now i'm sort of curious as to
how this is being adopted across the
industry and if you're seeing
some good traction in the project
so we have the community edition that's
available
it's uh for non-commercial use and it's
closed source so at this stage people
cannot really
outside people from ibm contribute
yes uh but we want
a lot of research to be done in this
area that's why
we are open this uh this way for people
to really do their research and
non-commercial
playing with it uh besides that we have
a product and we have different uh
scenarios where
we have been uh trying to deploy it in
different
in different uh real systems uh one of
them is for instance for
premature babies this is a startup uh
that's trying to
create machine learning models to
predict um
whether somebody is going to be needing
a particular treatment
so that's something that that it's out
there there's also
in the imaging scenario
where different hospitals and different
locations may have
information like x-rays or mris and so
forth
how can we use federated learning to get
a better
predictive model that's uh another use
case
banks trying to to see whether
for instance uh there's fraud
for those of you that have tried to
create a machine learning model that
that detects fraud one thing that you
would
think right away is that there's a lot
of data that is benign
uh but the percentage of data that you
have to learn how
to detect fraud is like super tiny
so every time that we want to detect
fraud federated learning
helps because that means that for
instance companies
they all have more samples for fraud and
that way you kind of expand your
knowledge in that
that unbalanced place of your data
got it and and where can people find
more work
uh more info on your work on the on the
fl
library i can share that
okay share that that slide so that i can
actually
uh give them the different uh urls
uh i i'm not super used to webex uh
to zoom so that you probably notice
that that's the case uh let's see
can i show this okay yeah so
i i would love if you check it out and
let me know what you think about
our framework we're always looking
forward to learn what people
have um think about it
so uh this is the oh this house internal
webpage but
you can see here the external library uh
for commercial use
and it's available in ibm watson machine
learning
and yeah so this okay
oh there we go yes and this is how folks
can contact you in case
um they they want to weigh in or have
questions for their questions about
federated learning
indeed indeed yes excellent
if you like our friend or give us a
start i love stuff yeah that's right
good old github stars um
well natalie this has been a fun
conversation and um i really appreciate
you
bringing your expertise to our community
and um talking about these
interesting topics i can see how it
requires a lot of experience from
um distributed systems to crypto
to um there's there's all kinds of
interesting
um sort of complicated things converging
in this field and so
um it seems to be a very rewarding and
challenging field but
i'm really grateful that you came to
share your uh your knowledge with us
thank you please my pleasure to be here
love talking yeah awesome
yeah okay well we'll uh we'll we'll talk
to you soon
thank you um thanks to
everyone for joining us uh
this has been a great episode and and as
you know we have
other episodes coming up which will be
announced soon
um don't forget to to sign off or sound
off with your feedback
we'd love to hear what the community is
thinking and we hope you'll join us for
another